and welcome back to Lone Prime daily
everybody we continue our coverage of
the Murdoch murder mystery in small town
South Carolina jury selection finished
Wednesday afternoon with 12 jurors and
six alternates picked now one of the
issues that the jury might hear in the
coming days concerns Financial crimes
that Alec Murdock allegedly committed on
Tuesday the prosecution and the defense
presented arguments to the judge about
whether or not to include those misdeeds
in this criminal trial
Mr Murdoch was confronted the very
morning of the Murder by his own Law
Firm seeking missing fees that's the the
temporal connection of those two events
that then tie back to literally a decade
of embezzlement that that one question
begets another which begins another to
understand why these are significant the
jury has to understand that he had been
stealing for over a decade 99 counts to
date and facing essentially life without
parole on these particular Financial
accounts and that's the significance of
what he was trying to prevent from being
exposed
the South Carolina attorney general's
office filed 99 charges against Murdoch
for these alleged Financial crimes in 19
indictments he's accused of stealing
more than eight million dollars as part
of a Ponzi scheme but the defense says
true or not that has nothing to do with
the murder of Murdoch's wife and son
there is no dispute anywhere that they
were the perfect family in terms of
their relationships no divorce no
separated no left him no nothing so this
is a fabrication and they want to use
what Mr Griffin described as bad
character evidence he stole all this
money so he must have killed his wife
and son
all right let's dive into this Brian
what decision did the judge make when it
comes to introducing Financial crimes as
evidence
the judge basically said maybe he ruled
against the prosecution's motion
eliminated to introduce the financial
crimes but left open the option of
arguing if the evidence should come in
as the trial continues the individual
pieces of evidence of the financial
crime face more scrutiny compared to
getting a ruling before the trial it's
like a football coach being able to
throw a yellow flag at every play or VAR
for every tackle for my kind of football
fans as different Witnesses take the
stand the judge is going to hear
arguments outside the presence of the
jury and witness as to whether or not
specific evidence of that crime should
come into this double murder it makes a
trial a lot harder for the prosecution
instead of just making one argument and
scoring six pieces of evidence they have
to go six for six to get as many points
it's just a different type of game
yeah right Brian I mean this could have
repercussions down the line during trial
but in my opinion the judge should have
made a ruling either to exclude or to
allow Murdoch's Financial records by
waiting for this trial to begin there is
a serious risk of delaying the entire
trial listen the whole point of emotion
and lemonade is to determine evidentiary
issues before the trial when judges
timely make those decisions then the
trial can proceed without extensive
interruptions the other issue and this
is really important it also allows the
parties to better prepare for their case
for instance the attorneys they need to
know what they can say or what they
can't say in the opening statements it
just makes life easier for everybody all
around I don't know Brian Terry makes a
pretty good point what other reasons
could the defense have for keeping that
part of the case separate well one is we
like to make cases difficult but aside
from that is I get the prosecution
believes these crimes are connected but
I think the defense's response would be
proven evidence doesn't come in just
because a prosecution can dream it up
but because they can prove there is some
relevance to the charges otherwise the
defense has a strong argument for
keeping that evidence out or winning on
appeal if the judge gets it wrong in
their motions the prosecution argues
that Murdoch saw the walls closing in on
him in the civil case that the
plaintiff's request for Discovery was so
strong and so imminent that it drove him
to shooting his wife five times in his
youngest son twice a bizarre Theory but
how do they come to him but why would he
do that and the motion wasn't even
decided before the murders and in fact a
similar motion followed by another
defendant in that case was denied so
Murdoch probably would never have to
turn over this financial formation also
I don't see how a lawyer would be able
to testify at trial that they knew the
outcome of a trial or emotion who do
they think they are a host of alarm
crime daily how dare they I mean so why
is the prosecution pushing for it Terry
you know actually the prosecution argued
that it wasn't trying to predict what
judge Hall would eventually rule just to
clarify judge Hall is presiding over
that wrongful death lawsuit brought by
the estate of Mallory Beach and the
beach family requested those records
because murder claimed he doesn't have
any resources to pay so the beach estate
has every single right to request those
financial records under those
circumstances now the prosecution in
this criminal trial they also want those
records but they argued that the jury
has to understand you heard him say this
what has been happening over the past
decade as far as the finances are
concerned and so that's why they want
that in there it's going to the motive
frankly I agree with the prosecution all
of this is relevant it's more probative
and I think it should come in and I
think they should decide it now all
right you make good arguments we'll wait
and see stay with the long crime Network
for gavel to gavel coverage of the
Murdoch family murder murders we're
going to be bringing you the very latest
here on Long crime daily and of course
you can check out everything from videos
to court motions online